see how you see that kind of charcoal in
the cake
it's just that little
i'm assuming you're offering
mr kent
he said you'd come
now let's hope you're not too late
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new superman justice
league snyder cut video
zack snyder explained a little bit about
what's going on with the black suit
during the movie
why he used it why superman is wearing
it where it came from
he also dropped a crazy looking
steppenwolf preview for what he's going
to look like during the movie so we'll
break it all down
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the easter eggs
dc fandom is coming up in a couple weeks
there is going to be a
ton of dc movie trailers and footage i'm
going to try and cover as much of that
stuff as i
can but just starting with the black
suit superman stuff then i'll talk about
the steppenwolf stuff
i'll just number these as we go along
and talk about easter eggs a little
while ago you probably saw zack snyder
released a new justice league snyder cut
trailer of black suit superman
showing up to talk to alfred before he
went to join the rest of the justice
league and fight off steppenwolf at the
end of the movie in that big final
battle
because the snyder cut is over four
hours long a lot of the subplots a lot
of the story is very very different from
the theatrical cut
but they were still going to have a big
final battle superman was going to show
up to help out in the snyder cut so at
least on that level there were some
similarities even though the fight
itself went down very differently
but a lot of people saw this scene and
recognized it as a different version of
another deleted scene that we'd already
gotten a couple years ago after the
theatrical cut came out
and not just an alternate take of a
similar scene but the exact
same scene moment for moment and the
only difference is that superman is
wearing the black suit from the comics
instead of the classic red blue and
yellow suit so zack snyder told this big
story about where
this black suit came from why superman
chooses to wear it in this version of
the movie in the snyder cut
and what he had to do what zack snyder
had to do to accomplish the actual suit
itself
on screen it's all fascinating and some
of it's kind of funny too the way he
talks about it
if you remember way back before the
theatrical cut came out when they were
still doing reshoots people were talking
about black suit superman
there were a lot of theories about how
it was going to show up during the movie
zack snyder's story debunks a couple of
those rumors and confirms a couple other
ones
but the way he explained it is that
superman gets his black
suit from this other deleted scene which
is just more snyder cut footage of him
going to the kryptonian ship the
dceu version of the fortress of solitude
after he's been raised from the dead
after he's talked to lois when he's
getting ready to go
during the justice league so it's
happening before this alfred scene
[Music]
so you see superman going to a different
wing of the kryptonian ship looking at
the different armor he has available to
him
a lot of you saw this and freaked out
about that kryptonian warframe it would
have been really cool for him to step
into that for a couple minutes
you notice the black suit behind him too
but this is just meant to be an
easter egg for the return of superman in
the comics if you didn't read that
storyline they did a version of that in
the animated movies in the reign of the
superman but it was very different from
the comic book version
when superman died a bunch of mystery
supermen pop up when he comes back to
defeat cyborg
superman who's the real villain of that
story arc he comes back
inside a warframe wearing the black suit
with the biggest mullet that you've ever
seen
because this is all happening back
during the 90s that's why when people
were posting all the fan art of henry
cavill in the black suit they were
drawing him with mullets just because of
the comic book story line
and there were a couple reasons why he
picked it instead of the classic
red blue yellow suit the first reason
was a more practical reason
zack snyder explained that during his
fight with doomsday in batman v superman
you had this giant spike driven
through the classic suit so it was
effectively damaged he couldn't just
throw it back on again and he didn't
have the skills himself to know how to
repair kryptonian fabric like that
i'm sure given enough time the
kryptonian ship could have given him the
instructions to repair the suit
but he needed to join the fight the
clock was ticking in the black suit was
just sitting there
ready to go so that's why he put that
one on instead
the other more thematic reason why zack
snyder said he's wearing the black suit
during this movie
is because of his overall arc that
started with man of steel and went
through batman v superman
so he said during his movies starting
with man of steel he wanted to take
superman on this full arc
first discovering what it means to be
superman where he fits in with the world
how he relates to humanity through lois
lane why she's such an important
character
how he becomes this big symbol for the
people earth's greatest protector its
greatest hero
but he wasn't going to get to that point
till the end of justice league after he
comes back from the dead effectively
the whole subplot with the evil black
suit superman stuff during the snyder
cut was just him at his lowest point
then you have lois lane showing up
effectively saving him bringing him back
from the brink
so the black suit is just the next step
in him hitting his peak eventually at
the end of the first justice league
movie they were going to be heading into
the second movie with him just being
full-blown classic
comic book superman the way you expect
him the greatest version of superman
the reason why the actual black suit is
sitting here on the kryptonian ship
waiting for him though because superman
didn't make it himself it's just sitting
there ready to go
is because this scout ship is from the
house of l and their crest has not
changed in thousands of years the ship
has been sitting here for a long long
time in the ice
you notice in that man of steel prequel
sequence where you have zod you have
jor-el you have the other kryptonians
they walk around in those base layers
underneath their armor
they're all black suits it's literally
just what it is it's just superman's
base layer
intended to go underneath kryptonian
armor but because of superman's
abilities under earth's yellow sun he
doesn't need armor so he just
wears the base layer as a normal suit
the way the dc
people refer to the suit during this big
behind the scenes promo is as the evil
superman sued also just confirming some
of the subplots during the snyder cut
it's more of him just fighting the
justice league that's why they're
calling it evil superman
a lot of that gets into the way superman
is resurrected during the snyder cut
remember a lot of the plot is going to
be very different so the way they
resurrect him during the snyder cut will
be completely different from the
theatrical cut
the way that zack snyder said that he
practically accomplished this black suit
scene is kind of hilarious with him
fighting with the studio
so he said the studio would not allow
him to use the black suit in the scenes
so they never built a practical black
suit for henry cavill to wear so
when he's walking around in the snyder
cut filming all these scenes
he's wearing the classic red blue yellow
suit that's why in all this henry cavill
behind the scenes footage of the snyder
cut you see him wearing the classic suit
so in order to try and win the studio
over to let him use the black suit
they just photoshopped all these scenes
to black suits superman so you just have
to imagine henry cavill filming in the
regular suit and then them just
tuning the suit black desaturating it
just changing the colors
making the cape look kind of charcoal
it's funny to think of them doing the
movie that way but zack snyder said it
was all just because the studio was not
happy with the concept of the black suit
so he was hoping to sort of sneak it in
under the wire at the last minute they
had all this footage of him with a
regular suit like the studio wanted but
they could just click a couple buttons
and turn the suit black if they ever
said yes at the last minute
now that hbo is releasing the snyder cut
next year they're letting him do
whatever he wants to with it he can do
all that black suit stuff so a lot of
their post-production
is just tuning the suit black in all
these scenes that henry cavill filmed
the way he explained it he said the
studio's objections to the black suit
were mostly that they felt like it was
too depressing and dark even though zack
snyder tried to convince them otherwise
like no it's a big comic book easter egg
but the people at the studio that said
no
they all got fired a long time ago the
deal with the new steppenwolf preview
this is what he's actually going to look
like during the movie you can kind of
tell where this scene takes place it's
that same
fight that they put in all the old
justice league theatrical cut trailers
so it's the justice league minus
superman fighting him in that giant
water cooling tower this is just zack
snyder getting everyone hyped up for
that and i do love the fact that he
drops a bunch of f-bombs in his caption
he dropped a bunch of f-bombs during his
big live stream at comic-con
just casual f-bombs like it's no big
deal keeping it real
what's going to be happening in the next
couple weeks though is dc fandom is
going to be a saturday event they said
it's only
around for 24 hours i don't know how
they plan on releasing all the trailer
footage but i'll do as many of those
videos as possible
there'll be a justice league snyder cut
trailer a full version of the trailer
there'll be a big matt reeves robert
pattinson panel for the batman movie
i don't know if there's any footage or
any behind the scenes that they're going
to show off for that if they do of
course i'll do a video for it hopefully
they'll reveal some of the other
villains some of the other parts of the
movie
robert pattinson was also telling some
funny stories about how he auditioned
for batman and he tried to lie to
christopher nolan
because he was filming tennant while he
was auditioning for the batman movie
the way he tells it is that he told
christopher nolan he had a family
emergency as an excuse to get off of set
but christopher nolan immediately knew
exactly what he was doing you're going
to audition for batman
aren't you the rock also posted a teaser
for the black adam movie so there might
also be a bigger black adam teaser
hopefully they'll also reveal some more
michael keaton batman stuff too for the
flash movie
but while you wait for everything click
here for that brand new wonder woman
1984 trailer video
and click here for that brand new boys
season 2 trailer new episodes coming in
a couple weeks
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you